hi there steve kaufman
here and today i want to talk about
learning three languages
in the same day because i've changed my
strategy and i'm going to explain why
and i'm going to provide some background
some people will say gee steve you used
to say you should focus entirely on one
language and i did use to say that but a
number of things have changed
i have come to realize that
you know the more you focus on one thing
to try to nail one thing you stay with
one thing there is a point when the
efficiency the learning efficiency
declines
i find that uh
you know listening to arabic or
persian
stories that by about the second or
third story
that i'm reading or listening to i am
less focused less curious less hungry i
notice fewer things
that's one thing now i had mentioned
before that i was going to study three
languages over the next say year or so
three months on arabic three months on
persian and three months on turkish and
that was my intention
then i saw a video where a polyglot that
i greatly admire luca lampariello
who said he was doing three languages a
day
can't remember which ones i think danish
was in there
and he was spending 30 minutes on each
so i thought well if luke is doing that
maybe it's something that i should try
and so i've started doing it and the
advantage is
first of all that you are introducing
more variety so before you get stale in
one language you move on to another and
so it's new and it's it's fresh and
you're more curious
uh and i do find that since i started
doing this two days ago
i do notice things more especially when
listening but also even when reading
and uh now i am working on the mini
story so it's it's largely a matter of
refreshing where i was because i was
away for a month traveling and i dabbled
a bit in cerebral croatian and and of
course the last language i did was
turkish and so now my arabic is a little
bit rusty so
um the first thing of course is that i
find that i notice things better the
second thing is that there's less time
to forget things so it is a bit annoying
if i meet an arab arabic speaker as i
did in spain and i have to present
excuses that well yeah i was studying
arabic but for the last six months i was
doing persian and turkish and now i
can't remember my arabic and so this way
i can maintain them all every day
because i do
say two or three as i said i'm focusing
right now on reviewing my mini stories i
want to do two three four mini stories
in each language every day and i do the
same ones in each language which has the
advantage that i'm you know aware of the
context of the story because i just
finished doing it in another language
and that sort of helps
so i'm going to do that
and we'll see how it goes now people say
well you're contradicting yourself yes
i'm contradicting myself
but
the number one rule in language learning
is to enjoy it
and so
experimenting with different ways of
learning is a way of enjoying it you've
got to have fun now
obviously this learning strategy is
going to depend on your situation when i
was learning chinese
i worked for the canadian government
i had a job to learn chinese so i was
totally focused on learning mandarin
chinese
and yet even there i did have variety
because i had three hours a day of one
on one classroom instruction with a lot
of drills i had to spend a fair amount
of time every day on characters and on
writing so and then i did a lot of
listening and i also scoured the
bookstores of hong kong to find new
material to listen to and read so there
was within my mandarin learning activity
i tried to introduce as much
variety as possible
so that's one situation but now i'm
learning for fun so those of us who are
learning for fun we can experiment with
whatever system we want the main
objective is to enjoy it if you enjoy
the activity you will improve i'm quite
convinced of that
and the other you know the advantage to
me is that if i can do three a day three
languages a day say half an hour on each
particularly varying the listening
activity and if that enables me to
progress now bear in mind probably the
first month i'll be focused on the mini
stories kind of to get back to where i
was and make sure that that's you know
firmer in my mind then as i go to you
know explore new material i won't have
the advantage of being able to do the
same story in different languages so
we'll see how that all works but if it
is successful it means that
at the end of nine months rather than
being six months removed from my arabic
in fact i will have all the three
languages with me learning them all
together and i and i think that that you
know we should experiment with language
learning because unfortunately language
learning and language instruction for
too long
has been the preserve of the language
teachers so the assumption is that you
learn in a classroom
what you may learn in a classroom
but it's also just as likely that you
what you do outside the classroom is
more important than what you do in the
classroom the reason why people in
sweden and holland
or croatia
speak english well is because they have
so many movies and television programs
in english or in the original language
for other languages so it's not because
necessarily language instruction in
croatia or sweden is superior to
language instruction say in spain
i also once saw a study put out by the
american
center for linguistics or something
which traced
you know the influence of
english instructional instructional
hours
on how well immigrants did in learning
english and the
while they
sort of crowed about the benefits if you
looked at the results you sh it showed
that in some cases increased
instructional hours meant a decline in
english proficiency which really only
demonstrated that there was no direct
relationship there was all kinds of
difficulty measuring how well people are
doing
uh
and in fact
those immigrants who had friends
in you know the united states this was
an american study or who worked where
they used english obviously we're going
to improve more than people who only
went to class and so that really the
instructional the idea of focusing all
language learning on the classroom and
therefore language learning
uh methodology or the best way to
proceed has to be based on what works in
a classroom i think that's basically
wrong i think serious language learners
should experiment with different ways of
learning
and um
you know this whole idea of learning
more than one language of being a
polyglot is something that i wasn't even
aware of when i was studying chinese i
just had this one task
but i you know i didn't even know the
meaning of the word polyglot basically
because linguist was is the word still
in english that's used to describe
someone who speaks many languages
but as i learned more and more languages
i realized the benefit of varying it not
only varying the activities
but also varying the the language and i
find that it makes me more focused
better um you know more attentive to the
language
and of course the brain likes novelty
so i'm going to continue experimenting
with this
and we'll tell you you know we'll let
you know how it goes a small note here
um back of course for my trip to
croatian spain
but on the 15th i'm going to japan i'm
going to attend the polyglot conference
in fukuoka and i'm going to be in japan
from the 16th to the 23rd
seven days
uh
if anybody wants to have a meet-up i'll
be in fukuoka and osaka possibly tokyo
please let me know if there's any desire
for a meet up
i will make a presentation at the
fukuoka polyglot conference and also i
will leave a link here to
a presentation that i'm going to make
to a group of japanese language learners
this one will be in japanese
and you'll see the link and if anyone is
in fukuoka
also welcome to join it
[Music]
all right that was just again inviting
people to let me know if they won't have
a meet up so that's it and i will
continue doing my three languages a day
because i'm having fun with it all right
then bye for now
[Music]
you